992 GT3 unfallprojekt das wir wieder
aufbauen mich hat jemand nach den Kosten
gefragt genaue Abrechnung wird es am
Ende vom Projekt geben aber dieser
Bereich der gesamte Heckbereich ist ein
gutes Beispiel denn hier ist so ziemlich
alles kaputt Heckspoiler inklusive
Aufhängung ca 10000 € neu ducktail weil
es aus Carbon ist dieses kleine pissteil
kostet 5000 €. dreiteilige Heckleuchte
also linke Heckleuchte Rechte und dieses
Band durch 35000 € heckstürze grundiert
die dann auch noch lackiert werden muss
4000 EUR hier un dieses Plastikteil noch
mal ein bisschen was der Diffusor noch
mal 1000 die Abgasanlage 5 oder 6000
also irgendwo um die 30.000 quasi nur
für
Äußerlichkeiten das ist noch nichts was
mechanisch kaputt ist 30.000 € ungefähr
fürs Hack kauft man alles original bei
Porsche was wir tun werden alleall